assalamualaikum greetings of peace we
are back in Orlando and if some of you
don't remember we had an interview a
very nice young man by the name of Chris
he's a security guard at the local Jamia
Masjid here and we talked to him and we
cleared up some misconceptions we had a
great time and he's still here working
so I'm gonna go ahead and follow up with
him see how he's doing if you haven't
seen that interview that we did with him
and go ahead we'll have it in the
description below let's follow up with
Chris and see what he's up to
alright let's go hook up with the
security guard Chris comes from a
Christian background and many sincere
genuine Christians out there who've been
misled by the media the false hype but
he got to connect because he's doing the
SCAR security guard work here
with a lot of Muslims he made the human
connection and he was also motivating
people to connect with the Muslims and
here he is Chris hey what's going on
remember this friendly face yeah how
time flies what was it about a year ago
I was out here about a year man yeah say
me man did you get some feedback from
the interview we did yes I got a lot of
feedback from the school from the mosque
[ __ ] everything like that a bunch of
teachers they actually like out there
yeah it was pretty fun I liked it a lot
um some of the things that I just
noticed is that his YouTube channel is
literally connecting and hitting with
everyone on the basically social media
scale had a positive feedback from many
people I know that yeah positive
feedback awesome tell me what else has
been new since the last time we've we
spoken a lot a lot of the things on time
has basically come basically that a lot
of things get make make you busy I would
say so you just got a be time oriented
and a lot of things that um I forgot I
forgot what your name is again buddy
Eddie Eddie he came up to me you know
he's basically sharing his faith with me
and the thing is he's just sharing a
mess of positivity and because of that
you know I took that into the entire
year and I just not let stress get to me
you know you got to be positive and say
it's positive as you possibly can
I remember the last time we talked about
you know the simple message of what what
is
is about when we went over that the
oneness of God right that God Almighty
sent messengers they all came with the
same message worship the Creator not to
Croatia exactly this life is a test
we're being tested each and every day
each and every day and then from here we
go on we move on and it's either the
reward paradise how far this is what
Jesus brought the same message Moses
Abraham they all brought that same
consistent message because the Creator
he's not the author of confusion it was
always that same message but now there's
a lot of obstacles why because many
people they start to I think we touched
upon that here the media all Muslims are
terrorists all they oppressed their
women did we touch upon those basic
things yeah yeah last last time we
definitely touched upon the things um he
brought about a lot of things that
people are trying to how what I say uh
basically construe the message of the
media and um whatever the media you guys
telling you listen if they're not a part
of the actual place I wouldn't even
listen to the media outlet if someone's
trying to make a message about a
particular belief or a particular
country or nation and they're not even
from the place they publish a whole
overseas you know they're not really
getting the exact message that they're
trying to portray and I think that most
of the time people they like to make
gossip you know that's one thing you're
not supposed to get into don't try to
gossip don't try to make up ideas and
stories that you're not supposed to
because these guys are completely
different they're doing the exact
opposite that the media is trying to
portray the mess that's deep man and
you're getting to hear from a Christian
right Christian background Chris and he
has been spending a lot of time here as
a security guard protecting the mustard
the moss and it's unfortunate that we'd
have to this was some time not too long
ago where there was no such thing as
like security guards and moss and it's
an unfortunate that we have that today
so we clear up a lot of the junk that's
thrown out there we look at this way of
life as a treasure right a treasure for
all of humanity and now there's a lot of
junk thrown on it you got to dig a
little bit and these misconceptions that
are out there a lot of the hype things
out of context you clear them out of the
way and then you come to you know what
we're really trying to to espouse and
trying to relay to people is to really
think okay where did I come from this is
something that really every human being
about where did I come from why am I
here and where am I going when I leave
this earth I just fall asleep and that's
it it's done no no a whole new world
opens up so that's like the first place
that we have people start to really
reflect like what's the purpose of life
why am I here and the D show really
helps to articulate that message you
know and try to bring that to the people
and then you have a free choice either
to accept if you like what we have to
say accept it if not reject it but at
the end of the day and we always
motivate people to ask the crater alone
for guidance right there's an authentic
tradition by a prophetic statement by
the last and final messenger from
Muhammad where he said that God is
saying that all of my slaves meaning God
is like all of my slaves meaning mankind
humans everything that God created like
from the human beings are misguided
except if I guide them God is saying
this so ask me of my guidance so God is
saying ask me so this is this is like
the basic place where we ask people to
start is that we ask earnestly the
Creator alone to guide us you ask the
Creator why am I here what's my purpose
and then be courageous enough when that
shirt the truth comes right to accept it
to look into it you know and be genuine
and sincere so this is the kind of
message that we get out there and at the
end of the day if a person doesn't want
to accept that we've at least you see
every much every Muslims duty to share
right right to give that invitation but
then at the end it's up to that person
is between them and God we cannot force
someone over someone right that's
between them and God but it's our duty
just to share and then be of noble
character good manners and represent
Islam as it should be represented not as
some you know fringe element that's out
there Zac and then what they do is the
media goes and highlights them as if
they represent Muslims in Islam another
thing that I definitely want to touch on
- listen I've been working here a long
long long time you know so um I could
definitely be lit a fire with this arm
brother Dean is saying that they don't
like to force anything on anyone they're
not trying to go up to you and try to do
this or that you know they're they're
not do
their message is a piece all they want
to do is just if you want it if you if
you're if you have the faith you know an
imino of a little mustard seed faith of
anything so small that you want to grow
into it they're trying to preach to you
they're trying to talk to you like
listen hey we got this thing that you
might find you know that it might
actually help you out whatever you're
feeling you know they're trying to help
the bad out of people they're trying to
help the the lost souls of people you
know I see a lot of people walking with
their heads down heads into the social
media not paying attention to the entire
world and I see a couple people coming
up you know a lot of people from the
street and some of the people from the
Masjid going up to them and just saying
hey man would you like to come inside
and they're just basically trying to
enforce their himself just trying to how
would I say bridge that gap that they're
missing in their life and I've seen a
lot of people come to the Masjid and got
converted you know in this entire year
and I like it a lot it's awesome you
know seeing somebody is so happy so
blessed I think I've seen three so far
so it's it's a good thing you know what
you know what what we say is when
someone accepts I don't know if you
remember from last time
Islam simply means to submit write your
will to the will of God Almighty the
creator correct and we talked about you
know in Arabic we say Allah and Aramaic
the language Jesus spoke he would say
Allah ha
hello Elohim this is the Semitic
language right right because the English
language did not exist at a time Jesus
didn't speak English his name was even
Jesus they were there was no English
language so we call Issa now what
happens is when someone says ok I want
to worship the Creator let's say you put
sticks and stones and bones you say I
don't wanna worship then you put a human
being you put animals they say I don't
want to worship any of that then you put
the Sun and Mother Nature some call it
all of the inanimate things I'm adamant
things they said I don't want to worship
any of that and then the person is
offered the concept of there's one verse
in the quran where god almighty is
saying of himself he says could who
Allah a hug notice I'm not Arab but we
have the language of the Quran memorized
by millions and millions and millions
that's how it's been preserved so I'm it
is just imagine if you're able to speak
or recite something of the original
language that Jesus spoke right so I
make this side note so I'm
residing in its original language even
though I'm not Arab I'm an American
citizen
Bosnian back awesome so God Almighty
saying cool Allahu Ahad
Allah who summit let me lead while
amulet what an Akula who could for one
had say he is God the one and only the
absolute the eternal he's not the father
of anyone nor was he father and there's
nothing comparable to God Almighty you
see so when someone says you know what
that's the concept of the crater that I
resonate with it connects with my heart
and soul I want to worship the Creator
not how I desire about how he sent
through the messengers and we say the
last and final messenger is Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
and many people don't know when you
accept Muhammad you accept automatically
Jesus Moses Abraham and all the
preceding message automatically because
they were brothers in faith they all
brought Islam submission to the Creator
not the creation now someone does that
we say he reverts back he comes back
everyone was born in a natural state of
submitting to the crater grows up his
parents take him away and he becomes the
religion of his parents his forefathers
when he comes back to the pure natural
way he reverts back to submission and
surrender to the creditor heavens in
earth so we say someone came back to
their original way that definitely
sounds like a mixtones that that
definitely sounds like a message of
peace to me you know that's not a
recover from my words it's just if he if
what this man is speaking brother Dean
is speaking is the truth and that's
definitely a message of peace and I
could definitely love to see see it grow
more no it's just it's just a thing
where you're trying to make sure that
you want to spread positivity and love
and right now that's all I'm saying you
know I can't definitely try to construe
anything I can't say anything from my
mind if that's the truth and that's
definitely a message of peace so if
you're out there if our brother Chris
anybody who wants to learn more about
Muslims in Islam they can come here to
this mosque also oh yeah you'll see a
welcoming face this is here in in
Orlando Orlando Florida the Johnny and
Masjid come on stopped on in hook up
with the Muslim community here learn
more
you can even call us 1-866-376-8255 is a
knee to the right direction where you
guys want to head out to thank you guys
for tuning in to the Deane show and that
was our brother in humanity Chris and
it's very nice to to talk to and
communicate with such nice people like
Chris open mind and and that's what it's
about at the end of the day it's the
Creator God Almighty Allah who guides
the hearts but it's on us just to share
so we go ahead and did our part we
shared the message at the end we give
the invitation if someone wants to
accept they accept if it makes sense to
them everything we're saying they accept
it if not you reject it you move on
doesn't mean we have to hate each other
curse each other do all sorts of crazy
and belligerent things no and you still
continue to to be good to people you
still continue to be have upright
conduct good manners good morals good
ethics you deal justly that's the legacy
that Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him left behind for
Muslim and at the end of the day we're
fulfilling our obligation we're a law
tells us in the Quran who do Allah
sabili Rebecca bill hikmah to invite all
to the way of your lord with wisdom and
beautiful preaching and at the end of
the day be of good character good
manners and from there you lead the rest
to the crater as a law as the Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
told us convey for me even if it's one
ayah and imagined everybody shared if we
were on that footing of good character
and people saw as being true ambassadors
to this way of life to Islam and at the
end the day remember you got to link it
back to the sponsor because people are
gonna think like oh hey these people got
civilized they came over here and now we
taught them how to act up right no it's
because we live by the Quran the
verbatim Word of God we live by the
example of the last and final messenger
sent a command kind powerful how many
pieces of busses be upon him and all the
other messengers Jesus being one of the
greatest we followed their example and
that's what teaches us to be of the best
noble character is this deen islam it's
for you it's for everyone accepted or
rejected us up to you and then it's
between you and the Creator thank you
very much and I'd like to end all the
confusion with this because many people
they also get confused what's the right
way I'll just follow my way the crater
Tilson tells us in the Quran or Mayombe
takig idol Islam Medina filet you
cobalamin hua hua feel here a team in a
house I mean whoever chooses other than
submission is surrendered to the crater
that happens in earth Allah as their way
of life as their Dean this is in one
word summed up Islam never will it be
accepted of them and then the hereafter
they'll be among the losers so this is
what we believe fully that Jesus taught
Islam he call people to submit their
will to the crater so did Moses and the
last
final messenger sent to mankind problem
aha may peace and blessings be upon him
the one who accepts this lives by it
benefits themselves their family and
humanity by it obeys their creator
follows all the injunctions peacefully
submissively makes mistakes god almighty
is the most loving the most merciful
you're gonna make mistakes but you
continue on striving at the end of the
day God is most forgiving but you die on
this way of life living it to your full
potential
you got Genda paradise turn away follow
your desires all the messages of God
warn the people of the Hellfire if they
do that that's that carrot-and-stick the
reward and Punishment it's not all the
same for everyone we can understand it
worldly things what about the ultimate
justice with the crater in his love stay
tuned in we're gonna bring you what
looks like a part of Italy doesn't it
beautiful look at that but are we
actually in Italy like us out the Deen
show okay thank you thank you thank you
bye you haven't heard about the Deen
show now you have tune in every week new
show and in between we give you some
nice gems every week the Deen show if
you're not catching us on the local
cable station in Chicago or on the
satellite channels you can go ahead and
subscribe right now to our YouTube
channel where if you subscribe you're
not going to miss out on all the new and
exciting shows that we have coming out
just for you cheese smell liquor you
look us up at the deed show
[Music]
some Brazilian Jujitsu you want to roll
you want to roll my blue belt let's go
let's go you want to should we do it it
reminds me of when you come into this
Dean this beautiful way of life there
are things in the culture that are good
and those are the things that we need to
be cognizant enough that go against the
pure monotheism for instance you might
have been customed to coming and you see
all of this why these this money that's
being thrown and usually what people do
is they make they say make a wish and
then they'll go ahead and throw that
money into the water fountain and then
they'll feel like okay then God or
whoever the their prank they're praying
to or many of these pagan rituals these
concepts and they hope that their wish
would be answered but in Islam the
beautiful thing is that when we make a
prayer it's only to God so you can take
that money and no matter how small it is
you can give it to the poor you can give
it in charity and this is what God
Almighty loves this is what he loves is
when you take that and use it for a
benefit of humanity and if you want to
make a prayer you pray for guidance you
pray for help from the creator of the
heavens and earth not throwing money
into the water making a wish and get
nowhere with it
wasting money and you actually destroy
your good deeds so make sure you pray
only to the creator of the heavens and
earth directly alone that's the pure
monotheism and as as small as an example
as that is as the penny throw or the
quarter throw the money throw into the
pond and to the fountain that's a sign
in himself the yearning that the human
has to connect with something outside of
this temporal world and while we're
saying is what we're saying is shift
that from something artificial something
fake that's not going to really produce
anything positive for you shift that
that need that desire that want to the
one who created you and that makes sense
and ask for guidance ask the creator of
the heavens and earth why am I here
what's my purpose where am I going when
I die because those are the three
crucial questions of the human being
needs to really ponder reflect and seek
to want to know how did we get here why
are we here and where are we going when
we die now you're really now I am you're
gonna check it out yes sir there you go
the Dean show you have a go that's take
care